moi j'ai toujours dit la meilleure des
médicaments ces boîtes monde pointent
qu'à toi la comédie dramatique mon ami
walid aborde sans détour la santé
mentale pour leur premier long métrage
adib alkhalidey et julien lacroix ont
voulu faire les choses autrement
on a fait un projet en dehors des
conventions les 70 pages du scénario
j'ai pas d'argent comme dans plusieurs
cas on a besoin d'argent ils ont demandé
de l'aide à leurs fans leur campagne de
sociaux financement a permis d'amasser
80 mille dollars le film en a coûté au
total 150 la différence et a subi pour
le moment par ses créateurs son
impressionnante distribution compte près
de trente acteurs tous y ont participé
bénévolement les acteurs ont accepté de
jouer non plus mais non rémunérée mais
un grand pourcentage des recettes vont
directement aux acteurs fait qu'au
moment où on se parle il est jeune et
déjà de l'argent qui s'en va dans les
poches des acteurs pour sortir encore
plus des sentiers battus pour le moment
le film est présenté
non pas dans des salles de cinéma mais
bien dans des salles de spectacles comme
ici au cégep lionel groulx et à la fin
de la représentation les deux humoristes
vont à la rencontre du public poser des
questions après ces malades ça te
comprendre aux gens qui ont marqué la
journée parce que 80 mm les jeunes ça
pose c'est quoi 80 films sur coup deux
formes et on n'en a aucune idée
à la fin de la projection le public rend
son verdict sur caen
traité de cette façon là un sujet
délicat comme ça qui on vient de
découvrir un acteur incroyable je viens
là croyez renversant j'ai trouvé
l'histoire très touchante des
personnages très attachants c'était
morehead state rocco mais pas un peu
négatif je sais des courants on en
voulait plus parce qu'à baden pour je me
crie après moult où mon ami walid est
présenté dans une quinzaine de villes
avec l'espoir pour ses créateurs qu'ils
se retrouvent dans un cinéma près de
chez vous ici julie jasmin voudront
radio canada montréal